we're here in atlanta side of super bowl
53 and the local nfl starting
quarterback and he has been since he was
the third overall pick in the 2008 draft
he's matt ryan with us here in person
2016 nfl mvp matthew how are you i'm
doing great ice ice baby right here
maddie ice is here does it i can't i i
feel like it was just yesterday and
maybe i'm getting old we're all getting
old but you've been in the league now
this is going to be your number
11 12. oh
my goodness 12. yeah that's crazy i can
remember you balling at boston college
it flies by does it not it goes way too
quick yeah um i feel like i was just
playing at boston college and here we
are going into year 12.
um i feel really good though i feel
young so that's where i kind of wanted
to go with you you win the mvp in 2016.
like this might sound crazy i don't know
nothing tell me to shut up if i am but i
really feel like the last two years have
been more impressive by you than that
year just because i always say like kyle
made it easy for you that year you guys
are such a machine where these last two
years you've made some unbelievable
nothings there type of plays do you feel
the same way about that or am i stupid i
feel i feel pretty good about it and
you're stupid
but not about that no i i agree with you
i feel like um
you know 2016 was a
was an outlier for our offense in terms
of
everything was open everything was going
our way right plays you know running
game running game was perfect guys
stayed healthy right the schedule was
set up well for us all those type of
things uh the last two years have kind
of been grinder seasons for us um but i
do feel like i'm at a point in my career
where i'm playing my best football and
week in and week out
um you know i'm putting a consistent
performance in yeah you hear these guys
who are in their 40s talking about
playing until 45 or who knows how long
tom brady's going to play do you have an
outward limit that you're targeting at
this age like 50 55
that's like the direction we should be
going i you know i don't have a number
uh but as long as i feel good and i feel
like i'm playing well you know
i i really feel like
the rules are set up more favorable than
they've ever been for the quarterback
position to play longer and i feel like
i'm in a really good spot in terms of my
training and my health so i'll play as
long as i feel good yeah um i mean you
you saw of course what happened to the
saints right in the nfc championship
game i didn't see what happened you
didn't see what happened to sure you did
but but you know you know
how heartbreaking that loss was for them
i don't mean to bring up bad memories
but i'm gonna bring it up i mean 28 to
three does that do you still have days
where you wake up in the morning and
just go like damn
i can't believe that happened yeah i
mean it never leaves you yeah you know
those kind of things never leave you i
think i'm much more comfortable being
able to talk about it right and to
process it than i was uh earlier on but
i always am going to use it as
motivation to to want to get back there
to want to change you know the the
outcome the next time we get that
opportunity and uh you know i think in
life you're going to have stuff like
that come up yeah and it's it's how you
respond to it and how you deal with it
and how you're better for it the next
time around right right a lot of people
in atlanta were very happy that the
saints aren't coming here for super bowl
53 that they aren't in your practice
facility all week did were you rooting
for anyone but the saints to come invade
atlanta i mean i'd be lying if i told
you yeah you're supposed to score that's
right like yeah
anybody but the saints but
you know watching that game you don't
want to see anybody go out on a missed
call or or whatever but um i wasn't too
upset that it was the rams that that
made it but you still got to hear the
patriots crap so that's annoying too
yeah uh commissioner for a day what
would you do about the the officiating
the replay review
something that would or wouldn't fix
what happened at the end of that game it
happens all the time you know missed
calls all that kind of stuff it's in
every game and um you know we were
talking about it before you came on
sometimes karma football gods whatever
yeah it just it finds you at different
times
i'm not sure there's a good solution to
it um whether you go to a challenge or
whatever i have to see what they come up
with yeah i am in favor of trying to get
it right but
it's not going to solve all the problems
it's not going to solve everything this
happens you know human error is is real
and and this kind of stuff happens you
got the chairman of the competition
committee who is a falcons employer is
there ever a monday where you go seek
out rich and say rich you got to do
something about this here look at this
play we have to fix this rich i wear
rich out
you know like what are we doing what is
this especially in the preseason you
know every year they have this like long
video new rules and point of emphasis
yeah and so it's like in the preseason
you're like rich what are we doing right
but a lot of it you know a lot of it is
good stuff and he's really knowledgeable
on it so i'll be curious when i get a
chance i haven't seen rich since the
season ended but i'll be curious uh to
talk to him this off season to see what
direction they think they're going to go
how about the direction of your team i
mean you got a new offensive coordinator
in town i was not the biggest fan of
steve sarkeesian nothing personal but
how do you feel about getting reunited
with dirk cutter
i'm excited you know you know
in this business there's going to be
turnovers so it's always disappointing
when one guy leaves but it's it's always
exciting when you get to work with a new
person for me it's like going back
to 2012 right
with dirk
but i'm a much different guy now i've
learned a lot of different things since
since my first go-around with dirk and i
feel like my time spent with kyle yeah
and learning a lot of what that system
brings and some of that time spent with
sarc
i think it'll be better i'm i'm i'm in a
spot where i know some things different
dialogue about things you like exactly
which i think will be really good and
at the same time he's done the same
thing in tampa and been away for a while
and they've been productive on offense
and scored a lot of points there so i
look forward to working with him yeah
how much of an advantage is it that
you've worked with cutter in the past
though because we know how the rules are
you can't meet with the coaches can't
talk to the coaches can't do anything
the fact that yes we're making a change
but it's a guy i've worked with before
it's going to be a lot more seamless
when you finally can work together i
think what's what's what's even better
the scheme is the scheme right like
you're gonna learn that and and you'll
be on top of that what's great is i know
how he is game day in game he knows how
i am how we operate i know how we work
together during the week the
communication has always been really
good between he and i so there's there's
not that that learning curve that you
usually have to go through when you
change coordinators yeah right i mean um
so super bowl week just go back to your
experience that week what what jumps out
to you you know besides the game like is
there anything that jumps out to you
that you wish you would have handled
differently or even just something that
you thought like man that was really
amazing i mean what's the first thing
you think of other than the game
uh
is it hard to prepare that week i mean
i'd always
yeah
it's
we did a good job i thought we did a
good job um
first of all i had a really good
quarterback room your brother was with
us that year right matt schaub was with
us that year we had like a really good
setup to where we all worked well
together which i thought helped me that
week when everything was so different
we had a good crew that kept it light
uh which was which was important i think
i think the biggest thing that you know
you have to be able to compartmentalize
because you want to be able to enjoy it
and enjoy that experience of being there
and all of the stuff that comes along
with it like this this experience and
all that stuff right i wish i could
compartmentalize better and then move on
and be able to you know enjoy that part
of it and not dread that part of it
right right
the uh the the evolution that you've had
over the time you've been in the nfl the
improvements you've seen in yourself
give us a nuts and bolts
tangible that that where you can
consciously note hey i've gotten better
with this throw i've gotten better in
this way i couldn't do this when i came
into the nfl
uh i mean there's so many things to me
number one is being able to get the ball
out on the plant like so like five step
drop on the plant to you know skinny
pose a skinny post a white and scout
whatever that is a 12 yard out those
kind of timing throws um
you have to live by them in this league
pass rush is too good and so tangibly
that's way better than it was early in
my career
the other thing i would say is
you know
getting the ball out of your hand in the
gun
quick is not the easiest thing to do
sure and uh like i've gotten way better
at that way more accurate yeah and i
think that's the way the league's going
it's so hard to protect like this
weekend how do you block aaron donald
yeah well you can't you got to get the
ball out of your hand tom does that as
well as anybody yeah right rodney
harrison came up here and said hello
earlier and i see this gatorade bottle
he is always always gatorade when we are
at nbc on sunday so i assume you are too
you've about polished that one off we're
going to work on ours tell us what you
have going on
so um i've partnered up with gatorade
for a long time but this week i thought
it was pretty cool they've got a special
uh blend out peach blitz which pays a
little homage to uh the peach state here
in georgia the city of atlanta which is
cool it tastes really good so uh i've
enjoyed that but i'm waiting for it to
give me the effects that it's giving
rodney you know like i'm waiting for my
muscles to show up hey don't don't wait
too long it's not going to happen i'm
just telling you it's not in my car you
can't have everything okay all right we
got some fish bowl for you all right mr
gatorade here just random question dig
your hand in there i get to ask you no
no you're going to answer something
yourself oh you want me to read it or
you have any questions
what was your favorite childhood toy
matthew ryan
um
i'm going definitely nintendo the
nintendo system we had tecmo super bowl
oh man that i'm with you it's not even
close yeah that was uh i'm attacked most
of the world did you ever play that one
no that was kind of in the gap
atari with the little figures that
flashed yeah i never played ten for our
age group that was the first football
game that we got to play so it was it
was like battles between me and my older
brother just like full on back you would
win
uh you know 50 50 split but bo jackson
was unstoppable
unstoppable
so the raiders were off limits and when
we played each other falcons offense was
unstoppable a couple years ago we look
forward to seeing to get back to that
level matt as always it's great to see
you and we look forward to talking to
you again soon thank you guys matt ryan
we'll be back with more
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports